Speaker 1: Let's hear from a few more people in
the audience, we are taking calls via Discord
at David Pakman dot com slash discord. I hope
I pronounce this name correctly. Is Zephaniah
from Kansas, Zephaniah? Is that correct?
Speaker 3: Yes, it is. How are you? I'm
pretty good. I just want to say I'm a big fan of
your show, and I have a question about Joe Rogan
and his podcast, please. So a lot of a lot of
his episodes were taken down because of his use
of the N-word. So in a spot, you they don't have
people don't have freedom of speech on Spotify.
They're they're a private company. They can do
what they want. But would you support Spotify,
removing content from anyone who uses that
type of language? Because I think it's kind
of hypocritical for him to be his content to
be removed when he's using word in whatever
regard. And then you have, you know, rap artists
talking about killing people and destroying their
communities, using the N-word all the time.
So would do you think that would be fair to
just remove anyone who use that language?
Speaker 1: OK, so here's the thing. What I
what I want to see is Spotify, explain
the policy and apply it fairly now.
The policy could be OK, and I'm going
to this is where it gets complicated,
if Spotify wanted, they could say, Listen,
our policy is unspoken word podcasts.
We don't allow the use of the N-word,
except in what are clearly academic,
some kind of academic use where you have some
kind of sociology professor who's explained,
I don't even know, but like, look, we'll just say
the policy could just be unspoken word podcasts.
We don't allow the word. That being said, we
allow it in music or something like that. Now,
would that make sense? I don't know. I'm not sure.
I don't know if that would make sense. But what I
what I think has to be done is what, whatever
the policy is, it has to be applied to everybody.
It can't just be to Joe Rogan. That's
that's my priority. The next part of it is
there are tiny podcasts and musicians with
that. Almost nobody knows about that are
certainly using the word. And so then it becomes
the Spotify even have the wherewithal to police
every minute of audio that's on their platform. I
don't know. I don't know. But what I am absolutely
certain about is whatever the policy is, can't
only be applied to Joe Rogan, that's for sure.
Thank you very much. All right, my
pleasure. There's Zephaniah from Kansas.